you just kind of painted a beautiful
picture of comparison this is the way we
think about ideologies because we is
what's working better do you separate in
your mind the ideals of communism to the
Stalinist implementation of communism
and again capitalism and American
implementation of capitalism and as we
look at now the 21st century where yes
this idea you know of socialism being a
potential political system that we would
or economic system would operate under
in the United States rising up again as
an idea so how do we think about that
again in the 21st century about these
ideas fundamental deep ideas of
communism capitalism yeah so in the
Marxist schema there was something
called feudalism which was supposedly
destroyed by the bourgeoisie who created
capitalism and then the working class
was supposed to destroy capitalism and
create socialism but socialism wasn't
the end stage the end stage was going to
be communism so that's why the Communist
Party in the Soviet Union first built
socialism transcending capitalism the
next stage was socialism and the end
game the final stage was communism so
their version of socialism was derived
from Marx and Marx argued that the
problem was capitalism had been very
beneficial for a while it had produced
greater wealth and greater opportunities
and feudalism had but then it had come
to serve only the narrow interests of
the so-called booze huazi or the
capitalists themselves and so for
Humanity's sake the universal class the
working class needed to overthrow
capitalism in order for greater
productivity greater wealth to be
produced for all of humanity to flourish
and on a higher level so you couldn't
have socialism unless you destroyed
capitalism so
meant no markets no private property no
so-called Parliament's or bourgeois
Parliament's as they were called so you
got socialism in Marxist schema by
transcending by eliminating capitalism
now Marx also called for freedom he said
that this elimination of markets and
private property and bourgeois
Parliament's would produce greater
freedom in addition to greater abundance
however everywhere this was tried it
produced tyranny and mass violence death
and shortages everywhere it was tried
there's no exception in historical terms
and so it's very interesting Marx
insisted that capitalism had to be
eliminated you couldn't have markets
markets were chaos he needed planning
you couldn't have wait a hiring of wage
labor that was wage slavery now you
couldn't have private property because
that was a form of theft so in the
Marxist scheme somehow you were going to
eliminate capitalism and get to freedom
it turned out you didn't get to freedom
so then people said well you can't blame
Marx because he said we needed freedom
he was Pro freedom so it's kind of like
dropping a nuclear bomb you say you're
gonna drop a nuclear bomb but you want
to minimize civilian casualties
so the dropping of the nuclear bomb is
the elimination of markets private
property and Parliament's but you're
going to bring freedom or you're going
to minimize civilian casualties so you
drop the nuclear bomb you eliminate the
capitalism and you get famine
deportation no constraints on executive
power and not abundance but shortages
and people say well that's not what I
mark said that's not what I said I said
I wanted to minimize civilian
the nuclear bomb goes off and there's
mass civilian casualties and you keep
saying but I said drop the bomb but
minimize civilian casualties so that's
where we are that's history not
philosophy yeah
I'm speaking about historical examples
all the cases that we have Marx was not
a theorist of inequality Marx was a
theorist of alienation of dehumanization
of fundamental constraints or what he
called fetters on productivity and on
wealth which he all attributed to
capitalism Marx wasn't bothered by
inequality he was bothered by something
deeper
something worse right though socialists
who figured this out who understood that
if you drop the nuclear bomb there was
no way to minimize civilian casualties
those socialists who came to understand
that if you eliminated capitalism
markets private property and
Parliament's if you eliminated that you
wouldn't get freedom those Marxists
those socialists became what we would
call Social Democrats or people who
would use the state to regulate the
market not to eliminate the market they
would use the state to redistribute
income not to destroy private property
in markets and so this in the Marxist
schema was apostasy because they were
accepting markets and private property
they were accepting alienation and wage
slavery they were accepting capitalism
in principle but they wanted to fix it
they wanted to ameliorate they wanted to
regulate and so they became what was
denounced as revisionists not true
Marxists not real revolutionaries but
parliamentary Road parliamentarians we
know this as normal politics normal
social democratic politics from the
European case are from the American case
but they are not asking to eliminate
capitalism blaming capitalism blaming
markets and private property so this
rift among the Socialists the ones who
are for elimination of capitalism
transcending capitalism otherwise you
could never ever get to abundance and
freedom in the Marxist schema versus
those who accept capitalism but want to
regulate and redistribute that rift on
the left has been with us almost from
the beginning it's a kind of civil war
on the left between the Leninists and
the Social Democrats or the revisionists
as they're known pejoratively by the
Leninists we have the same confusion
today in the world today where people
also cite Marx saying capitalism is a
dead end and we need to drop that
nuclear bomb and get freedom get no
civilian casualties versus those who say
yes there are inequities there's a lack
of equality of opportunity there are
many other issues that we need to deal
with and we can fix those issues we can
regulate we can redistribute I'm not
advocating this as a political position
I'm not taking a political position
myself I'm just saying that there's a
confusion on the left between those who
accept capitalism and want to regulate
it versus those who think capitalism is
inherently evil and if we eliminate it
we'll get to a better world when in fact
history shows that if you eliminate
capitalism you get to a worse world the
problems might be real but the solutions
are worse from history's lessons now we
have deep painful lessons but there's
not that many of them you know our
history is relative short as a human
species do we have a good answer on the
left of Leninist Marxist versus social
democrat
versus capitalism versus any anarchy you
know do you have sufficient samples from
history to make better decisions about
the future of our politics and economics
for sure we have the American Revolution
which was a revolution not about class
not about workers not about a so-called
universal class of the working class
elimination of capitalism markets and
the bourgeoisie but was about the
category citizen it was about universal
humanity where everyone in theory could
be part of it as a citizen the
revolution fell short of its own ideals
not everyone was a citizen right for
example if you didn't own property you
were a male but didn't own property you
didn't have full rights of a citizen if
you were a female whether you own
property or not you weren't a full
citizen if you were imported from Africa
against your will you were a slave and
not a citizen and so not everyone was
afforded the rights in actuality that
were declared in principle however over
time the category citizen could expand
and slaves could be emancipated and they
could get the right to vote they could
become citizens non-property owning
males could get the right to vote and
become full citizens females could get
the right to vote and become full
citizens in fact eventually my mother
was able to get a credit card in her own
name in the 1970s without my father
having to co-sign the paperwork I took a
long time but nonetheless the category
citizen can expand and it can become a
universal category so we have that the
citizen universal humanity model of the
American Revolution which was deeply
flawed at the time it was introduced but
fixable over time we also had that
separation of power
and constraint on executive power that
we began this conversation with that was
also institutionalized in the American
Revolution because they were afraid of
tyranny they were afraid of
unconstrained executive power so they
built a system that would contain that
constrain it institutionally not
circumstantially so that's a great gift
within that Universal category of
citizen which has over time come closer
to fulfilling its original promise and
within those institutional constraints
that separation of powers constraint on
executive power within that we've
developed what we might call normal
politics left-right politics people can
be in favor of redistribution and
government action and people can be in
favor of small government hands off
government no redistribution or less
redistribution that's the normal
left-right political spectrum where you
respect the institutions and separation
of powers and you respect the universal
category of citizenship and equality
before the law and everything else I
don't see any problems with that
whatsoever I see that as a great gift
not just to this country but around the
world and other places besides the
United States have developed this the
problems arise at the extremes the far
left and the far right that don't
recognize the legitimacy either of
capitalism or of democratic rule of law
institutions and they want to eliminate
constraints on executive power they want
to control the public sphere or diminish
the Independence of the media they want
to take away markets or private property
and redistribution become something
bigger than just redistribution it
becomes actually that original Marxist
idea of transcending capitalism so I'm
not bothered by the left of the
right I think they're normal and we
should have that debate we're a gigantic
diverse country of many different
political points of view I'm troubled
only by the extremes that are against
the system cost system that want to get
rid of it and supposedly that will be
the right path to the future
history tells us that the far left and
the far right are wrong about that but
once again this doesn't mean that you
have to be a social democrat you could
be a libertarian you could be a
conservative you could be a centrist you
could be conservative on some issues and
liberal on other issues all of that
comes under what I would presume to be
normal politics and I see that as the
important corrective mechanism normal
politics and market economies non
monopolistic open free and dynamic
market economies I don't like
concentrations of power politically and
I don't like concentrations of power
economically I like competition in the
political realm I like competition in
the economic realm this is not perfect
it's constantly needs to be protected
and reinvented and there are flaws that
are fundamental and need to be adjusted
and addressed and everything else
especially equality of opportunity
equality of outcome is unreachable and
is a mistake because it produces
perverse and unintended consequences
equality of outcome attempts attempts to
make people equal on the outcome side
what attempts to make them more equal on
the front end on the opportunity side
that's really really important for a
healthy society that's where we've
fallen down our schools are not
providing equality of opportunity for it
for the majority of people in all of our
school systems and so I see problems
there I see a need to invest
in ourselves invest in infrastructure
invest in human capital create greater
equality of opportunity but also to make
sure that we have good governance
because governance is the variable that
enables you to do all these other things
you